the provisional referendum result was as
predicted by both the government which
says it's the people's will and the
opposition you say the vote was illegal
and rigged
the Electoral Authority said 95 of
Voters were in favor of changing the
Constitution
president falstan R Sean's twadera has
been in office since 2016. the
Constitutional changes would allow him
to stay for another 16 years
his government says they'll bring
stability and development
it was a question of meeting the needs
of the people the people are above the
president of the Republic so when people
ask for something we have an obligation
to respond it was necessary to propose a
new law turnout at polling stations in
the capital bangi was visibly low during
last week's vote
opposition and rights groups say they've
been threatened and attacked for
campaigning against the changes
called on people to boycott it and say
turnout was about 10 the Electoral
Authority says it was six times that
says
these elections could not be transparent
in almost all the polling stations there
were no ballot papers and ballot boxes
have been stuffed the only purpose for
which the president decided to change
the Constitution is to run again in the
elections in 2025.
madeira's government depends on Russian
mercenaries from the Wagner group and
Rwandan soldiers to control bangi and
some of the towns
the foreign forces benefit from access
to the vast mineral wealth including
golden diamonds
about half the population is in need of
humanitarian Aid and about half a
million people have been forced from
their homes
armed groups control much of the
countryside they also ordered people not
to vote
but for many staying safe and finding
food is more important than politics
after Decades of coups and conflict a
new constitution was adopted in 2016.
the government looks set to change it
the final results are expected in three
weeks
in the meantime the preliminary results
can be challenged in court but the
opposition say to adaira's government
already controls all the institutions
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera
foreign